Hi, I'm Jill Wilting, training chair of Algonquin District and the South Council, South Bend, Indiana.
This is the Scoutmaster Podcast, sponsored by Backers Like Me.
And now to you, Scoutmaster.
Hey, we had a great trip up to Algonquin Provincial Park in Ontario, Canada, this summer.
We had a great crew, we had great weather.
It's such a beautiful place to go canoeing.
We were up there for a week canoeing
And there was one night where the Scouts ran into the campsite out of breath
because they found a moose in the woods.
They saw a moose
And I said, well, was it a bull or a cow?
And they said no, it was a moose.
Hey, this is podcast number 281..
Hey,
Whoa,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Hey, I hope you enjoyed the Encore Podcast-
And you know when you get real fancy rather than reruns, you call them Encore Podcasts,
But featuring some of the interviews we've done over the past- 280-some podcasts
and some of my favorite ones.
But everybody's back home now
And we're all getting ready for a new Scout year to begin.
Summer Camp was great
And thanks to all of you who answered the Summer Camp survey at ScoutmasterCGcom.
If you haven't had a chance to do that, go, take a look
And take the survey if you would.
Boy, there's a lot in the mailbag
And let's see.
Let's do three or four this week and then we'll catch up.
It's going to take a couple of weeks to catch up,
But let's get three or four done here.
Christine Fitzgerald from PAC and Troop 7 in Warwick, Rhode Island,
wrote in to say I just wanted to thank you for your site.
It's a wonderful wealth of information for my role
as a fairly new Assistant Scoutmaster and Cubmaster.
Well, thanks, Christine,
I'm glad that you're finding what we do useful.
Gene Williams wrote in to say your columns make a difference in our troop.
Thanks, Gene,
I'm glad that we can be of service to you.
James Faircloth is an Assistant Scoutmaster with Troop 531..
He said: thank you, sir,
I really enjoyed your podcast and your book. so far, so good.
Hey, if you haven't read the book yet, it's available both in ebook and print versions
And you can also get an autograph copy by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer.
But we'll talk about that more in a moment.
David Copeland is with Troop 168 in Oklahoma City, Oklahoma.
He says thanks again for all the great resources and motivation you provide.
I'm technically already a backer after having signed up previously
And I thought it was now a good time to renew.
Your support is ongoing and in return, our support as backers should be the same.
I encourage anyone that's back to you in the past to do so again by being proactive
and to renew support each year.
Well, thanks, David,
I really I do really appreciate that, and our backers keep us going.
And we heard from another one, and you heard him at the beginning of the podcast here:
Joe Wilfing. he wrote to say today I became a backer of your podcast
which has helped me become a better scouter,
especially in my duty as pack trainer and pack 11 and district training chair
in the Algonquin District and LaSalle Council, North Central Indiana.
Great stuff.
Thanks so much, Joe.
I did manage to sneak in a couple of chat sessions, kind of under the radar
Over the past several weeks. we heard from Owen Wilson,
who's an assistant scout master in Phoenix, Arizona,
Eric Guter, who is an assistant scout master for Troop 131 in Holmdel, New Jersey,
And Mason Turner signed on to say hello.
He's a committee chair and we will, as den leader,
Impact 956 in Sterling Virginia
Now keep an eye open because we'll get back to like our semi regular live chat schedule,
usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings at scoutmastercgcom.
Keep an eye on the Facebook Twitter feed and come and join us.
So, before we go any further, let me talk about the backer program real quick.
Everything that we produce at scoutmastercgcom is there to help scouts
And, as you heard, people find it helpful,
Right?
So to keep everything freely available- because I'm never going to charge for
access to any of these resources-
I depend on people like you to become backers.
It's an unusual idea,
So let me take a moment to explain. if I was- oh, I don't know,
you know- sending out a paper magazine or newsletter,
you'd expect there to be some costs associated with that.
Right,
I'd need to pay a printer and whoever was writing articles, and I
need to pay for postage.
And what happens with things like a blog and a podcast is
actually pretty similar.
Somebody spends their time producing content,
incurs the expenses of publishing it and getting it to you,
And backers are folks who make a one time voluntary subscription
payment and those funds go to cover the expense of producing
and publishing everything that you find on scoutmastercgcom,
including the podcast you're listening to right now.
If these podcasts and the blog is helping you, go to
scoutmastercgcom. click the support link at the top of the
page
You'll find a number of options that will make you a
scoutmastercgcom backer
And woo, this is a long list.
I'd like to personally thank Sam Caligliari, John
Pandicchio, David Copeland, Mike Danshaw, Justin Dawson,
Joseph Wilfing, Dexter Decker and Steve Souter,
who all became backers since not our last podcast,
but our last podcast before we started doing the
encore presentations.
So once again, go to scoutmastercgcom,
become a backer this week and I'll be sure to thank
you during our next podcast.
Well, the email questions did not slow down very much
at all over the past several weeks
and we've got a lot of catching up to do.
I need to start answering some of these email
questions and that's going to take up the remainder
of this podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
So I had this question from a listener who asked to
remain anonymous.
They said: how do you deal with scouts who are
openly disrespectful to their parents, who are
volunteering as scouters, like the scoutmaster
or assistant scoutmaster,
And they're disrespectful at meetings and camps
and other outings?
This is not following the scout law and it makes
everyone around them uncomfortable.
Is this something the patrol leaders council should
discuss and address, or should only the
scoutmaster address this? but that has happened
and that doesn't seem to be working.
Should there be consequences and, if so,
who would decide them?
It seems like a big responsibility for youth
leaders to take on.
Well, that is quite a question,
and the answer isn't about who handles this
and how.
You're looking for procedural or logistic
answers to a question that's really about roles
and relationships.
Now, this makes it a little complex,
but it's not too hard to understand.
We have to examine first what's going on.
A volunteer scouter is a parent and has two
roles and relationships if they have a child
involved with the unit that they're
volunteering for
And they can't occupy both of those roles
and relationships at once.
A scout and a child also has two roles
and relationships if their parent is a
volunteer scouter.
The scout and the child, they can't occupy
both those roles at once.
We should add that there is a power
differential to consider too.
A parent has more power over their child
than a scouter has over their scout.
You can't use parent power in your
scouting relationship-
No fair.
And you can't use child power in your
scouting relationship either,
Because there's also the idea that a child
can push a parent's buttons more
effectively than they can provoke a
scouter, right,
And that's why I say there's child power
too.
Obviously, parent power stronger than
scouter power, child power stronger,
stronger than scout power.
And it's all about those relationships.
The problems start when the two
different relationships are allowed to
overlap.
If mom is the scout master and the
child is a scout, the child can likely
only sees mom right,
And really not the scout master.
And vice versa for mom,
Mom only sees her child and not the
scout. if you understand what I'm
saying,
If one or the other or both of those
relationships is strained, right,
If things are a little strained at
home between the parent and the child,
or things are a little strained at
scouts, between the scouter and the
scout, it's not really likely that
you're going to be very objective when
you try and switch roles.
Now the responsibility principally lies
with the adult in this equation
Who we hope has more mature character
tools to handle the situation.
So that explains the relationships
and the different things that bear on
them.
So let's talk about how this works
practically.
If you draw a line between the roles
of parent and scouter and of child
and scout and you make that line
the threshold of the meeting place
or the gateway of the campsite,
and you and your child have a mutual
agreement that the role changes
at that line, right?
So you define the difference between
the roles and how a parent and
child interact in one set of roles
and how a scout and a scouter
interact in another.
Since objectivity and the power
differential is always going to be
an issue in these situations,
the child of a volunteer
scouter should be encouraged to
make a free choice of a neutral
adult involved with scouting
to resolve any issues that might
come up.
Let's go back to my example again.
My mom's a scout master who is
subtly leveraging her parent
power and letting it overlap
with scouts, or that the child
is a scout and is
doing the same thing- kind of
leveraging the child power, right?
That neutral adult makes a judgment
and defines a resolution
and a lot of- and not nine out
of ten times- that resolution
is just going to be okay, guys,
you're mixing up the relationships.
You got to stop being that way.
come up with a hundred ways to define
being that way, right,
But you get the idea.
If either of them- either the parent
or the child- can't or won't stop
confusing these roles or making
a difficult situation, they really
just can't be a part of what's
happening in scouts, because we have
an oath and a law that defines our conduct
and our character, and if you can't follow
that, whether you're an adult
or a child, hey, we got a problem
and you're just not going to be able to participate.
Now this is all really simple.
It talks really easy, right.
If a parent
or a child scouts conduct
is not in line with the oath and law,
they simply can't be part of what's going on.
So we don't want to try to write rules
or standard consequences.
We don't want to give this to the youth leaders,
because we're really in this kind
of difficult area
where an adult relationship
with their child is involved,
and I don't want
to distract our youth leadership with
issues like that. That's something that's
going to be better handled by adults
And, like I said, no rules or standard
consequences. The only thing that's going
to work is dealing with issues
one at a time in the light of the
scout oath and law, Rules and procedures
and consequences and things like that.
they only change conduct. They don't
affect character. Dealing with people on
an individual basis as issues arise.
that's where we call on their character
And look for a post this week
on this subject. It's not just
about parents and scouts but
broader ideas about
conduct, character and
scouting. But anyway, if you have
behavior problems with
a scout who is being
disrespectful of their parent,
who is also a volunteer scouter,
or the tables are turned, you have a volunteer
scouter who is a parent who's
being disrespectful or difficult with
their child, who is also a scout.
It's not about procedures and policies,
it's about relationships and it always
goes back to those two
relationships getting mixed up and confused.
Jim, Who is
the Scoutmaster of Troop 309
in Morton Illinois, and Jim
wrote in to say: at a recent scout
roundtable the topic of
service hours for ranks came
up. A group of leaders says that
the time that Boy Scouts help
out at Cub Scout events
is not eligible to be counted
as service hours for rank
requirements, And these are
events like Day Camp or Pinewood Derby.
My response to them
was: what counts
as service hours is wholly
dependent on the scoutmaster's approval.
after all, the requirement states
that service hours
must be approved by your scoutmaster.
There was also a council director of operations
at the meeting and he said that helping at Cub Scout
events is not considered service hours
of eligible for Boy Scouts.
So I was wondering if I'm wrong in my understanding
of what counts as service hours
and I wanted to get your thoughts and insights.
Well, thanks for that question, Jim, and it's
really a pretty easy one to answer if we go to
the Guide to Advancement 2013,
because here's what it has to say on the subject.
In section 4.2
.3.3,
titled Service Projects-
quote: service
projects required from ranks other than
an eagle must be approved according to what is
written in the requirements and
may be conducted individually or through
participation in patrol or troop
efforts. They also may be
approved for those assisting on eagle
scout service projects-
Unquote. Now, the requirements for
star in life are worded identically.
while a first class
or star scout take part
in service projects totaling at least
six hours of work, these
projects must be approved by your scoutmaster.
So, Jim, you're correct.
in saying that there's no limitation
other than the scoutmaster's approval
is pretty simple right, because if there were,
it would either be written in the
requirement or it would be expanded
upon in the guide to advancement,
and there's no verbiage there
that affects that. Now, it's
pretty easy to resolve things like
this when people tell you something
that doesn't sound quite right
and that is just to politely ask
if they will show you where that is
written down. If they can't show you
where it's written down, it isn't so
and it doesn't matter if it's
10 to 1 scouters saying that
they know what's right and they're telling
you something, or if it's even
a council director of operations
telling you something
that you know isn't right. you know just.
hey, where is that written down? let's look at the
resource and get it sorted out and that way
you know. there's no argument or anything
like that, because it's already written down.
and these questions come up all the time,
you know, and that's why they're written down.
that's why we have the resources to resolve them.
I heard from Darren Brown who is
a scout troop in Utah
and he says I'm looking for direction on
organizing a small troop
of eight scouts. We were preparing
to elect a new senior patrol leader.
I'm wondering if we need to elect a patrol
leader or if that's just kind of redundant.
Do we need to make appointments for
assistant senior patrol leader, quarter master
scribe and all of that? We've had
a lot of positions of responsibility
in the past, like patrol leader and assistant patrol
leader, and sometimes scouts fill
dual roles in those
positions of responsibility.
but it always kind of felt redundant
and put us in a situation at times where
the patrol leaders council was everybody
in the troop but two scouts, which
seemed odd
and a little exclusionary to the
scouts who were not in the patrol leaders
council. I know you're mostly experienced
with larger troops, but I wondered if you had
any good advice for a smaller troop
in a rural area where joining another
unit or growing much past who we are
right now is not very feasible.
thanks for your great podcast.
well, Darren, it's pretty simple. right,
you have a patrol and that's all you need.
so where did troops come from?
did we start out scouting with troops?
no, we started out with patrols,
and you might get tired of hearing this,
but let's remember. you know, a century ago
scouting for boys was published.
boys started reading it, boys formed
patrols and then it became apparent
that, oh, you know what,
why don't we have three or four or five patrols
together in a troop?
uh, they can share resources and things
like that. so troops aren't very
important, are they? patrols
are important. so if you have
eight scouts, well, you have a patrol
and you'll have a patrol leader, an assistant
patrol leader, you'll have a patrol quartermaster
or patrol scribe. there's four
positions of responsibility
and the scouts can add on
whichever other ones they feel
are appropriate. in a patrol of eight
scouts, everybody should have some kind
of responsibility, and those roles
might change back and forth a little bit.
so let's not serve an organizational
imperative where we say, oh
wow, well, we're. well, we are called
a troop and that means
we needed a senior patrol leader,
assistant, well, it just doesn't make sense.
with that many scouts, right,
operators of patrol, it's great, it'll be fine.
and if you're concerned about,
uh, the tenure
requirements for rank, remember
that you only need to be concerned
about that when we're talking about eagle scout,
because for star
and life there is the
concept of a scout master
approved leadership project,
and also for
star life and eagle, the tenure
requirement can be fulfilled in any number
of roles. so what's more important,
the organizational imperatives of
the Boy Scouts of America or the
eight scouts that you're working with?
of course it's the eight scouts that you're working with,
right, and the BSA understands
that too. the thing is
that more often than not the talk is about
a big troop
rather than a smaller troop. so if
you're working with a smaller troop,
take a look at what you're doing and consider:
hey, we have a patrol
and if you go past the point of a patrol,
well then consider troop level
organization and leadership.
but I'll say for the third time:
what's most important
is the interests of the scouts
themselves and you find a way to serve
those interests and you'll always get it right.
so that's a few of the
man. it's a pretty big backlog
of email questions,
but I think that's enough for today
and you can get in touch with me with your questions,
and please do, and you're going to find out how to do that
in just a moment.
thanks for listening to this 281st
edition of the scoutmaster
podcast. you can keep in touch
by going to scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog
and the podcast by email.
you can experience
all of the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media
you can join.
I think it's about almost what
9,000 folks who like scoutmaster blog
on facebook
tweet, along with a chorus of 1200
and some tweeters on twitter.
you can pin the Pultritudinous pictures
profited publicly with 19 under the other
prolific pinners and Pinterest.
we've got some videos at scoutmastercg
on youtube.
and if you can't face facebook
and if twitter makes you bitter and you don't
have a whole lot of interest in Pinterest
and you don't put the you in youtube.
don't worry, bunkie,
zoom into the late 90s and fire me.
that's right. you can email me-
clarkgreen-
your comments, questions and
whatever wild ideas you might have
at clark. at scoutmastercgcom,
it's C-L-A-R-K-E.
at
scoutmaster
c-g?
com,
it only remains for me to remind you
the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster
podcast are not official publications
of anybody in particular, except for yours truly.
we're not sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America
or endorsed or sponsored by
the B-S-A
or any other scouting organization.
no, it's just me
talking into a microphone, trying to lend a hand to
scout leaders and have a bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here he is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pal.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you
and good camping.
well, I thank you, sir, until next time. everyone
bye.